It is time to wire up the buttons.
This will allow us to start
the audio playback and
change the state of the buttons.
Remember that when reaching from code
to UI element we'll use IBoutlets.
And from UI element to call our
code we'll use an IBAction.
We're going to start with IBoutlets.
Instead of dragging each button and
using the assistant editor,
an easier way is to write out
the IBoutlets in code and
then just connect them
via Interface Builder.
Open the PlaySoundsViewController.swift
file and
add the following lines
here inside the class.
These are the IBoutlets for the six
playback buttons and the stop button.
Now we just need to
connect these IBoutlets.
Open the Main.storyboard file and select
the play sounds view controller scene.
Make sure the document outline is open
and that you can see all the buttons.
With the Ctrl key held down, drag from
the Play Sounds View Controller down to
the SnailButton and
select the SnailButton as the outlet.
This has connected the ID outlet
named SnailButton to the actual snail
UI button.
Let's do the same for the other buttons.
With the Ctrl key held down, connect
the RabbitButton, the ChipmunkButton,
the DarthVaderButton, the EchoButton,
the ReverbButton, and the StopButton.
Now our view controller code can reach
out to all of the UI button using these
IBoutlets.
The next step is to connect the buttons
to an IBAction so that when
you press a button, the code inside
our PlaySoundsViewController will run.
From what you've learned so far,
you might be thinking we need to create
seven IBAction functions,
one for each button.
There's a better way,
with less duplication of code and
I'm going to show you that here.
We're going to create
two IBAction functions.
One to handle all six playback buttons
and one to handle the stop button.
Open the PlaysSoundsViewController.swift
file.
Underneath the IBoutlets you have just
created, add these two functions.
We have an IBAction function
to play the sound, and
we have an IBAction function
to stop playing sound.
Now we just need to connect
the six playback buttons to
the playSoundForButton IBAction.
We also need to connect the stop button
to the stopButtonPressed IBAction.
Let's go back to
the Main.storyboard file and
select the Play Sounds View Controller
scene.
For this step, it helps to have all the
buttons visible in the document outline.
You may need to open the disclosure
triangles as I've done here.
With the Ctrl key held down,
select the snail button and
drag into
the Play Sounds View Controller.
Select the playSoundForButton
function from the pop-up.
Let's do the same for the rabbit button.
With the Ctrl key held down, drag to
the Play Sounds View Controller and
select play sound for button.
Follow these steps for
the chipmunk button, the Darth Vader
button, echo button, and reverb button.
All six play buttons are calling
the same IBAction function.
For the stop button, we need connect
it to the stopButtonPressed IBAction.
Let's run and
see if everything is wired up correctly.
Press the run button here to start
Pitch Perfect on the iOS simulator.
Let's just quickly record and
stop so that we can transition to
the Play Sounds View Controller.
If we press on the snail
playback button, we can see
the playSoundForButton function is
getting called here in the console.
Let's try it for the other five buttons.
Lastly, let's check that the stop button
is wired up by pressing on it as well.
That was a bit of work.
But now we can reach into all of
the buttons from our view controller
using IBoutlets and have the button
call our code using the IBActions.
Now that our user interface is set up,
we can start writing our
audio playback code.